[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what is making the
headlines with the daily mails
consultant editor andrew pearce and the
daily mirrors associate editor kevin
mcguire great to see both of you and
you're here with us i know until just
before midnight so front pages then let
us start with the guardian it leads on
the nhs maternity scandal at the
shrewsbury and telford nhs trust with
police now examining 600 cases related
to baby and mother deaths
childbirth is not safe for women in
england is the way the times puts it
after the report's author warned many
failures were not unique to the trust
daily express highlights the voice of
one anguished mother who vows justice is
coming for every baby
the daily mirror also leads on the
scandal with the headline stolen lives
the metro meanwhile carries the story of
jamie wallace the conservative who today
came out as the uk's first transgender
mp and also revealed that he was raped
and targeted in a blackmail plot
the telegraph quotes from a speech by
sir jeremy fleming the head of the
intelligence organization gchq he's said
to give later claiming vladimir putin's
advisers are afraid to tell him the
truth about how russia's invasion of
ukraine is playing out
the financial times reports that the
german and austrian governments are
poised to ration gas supplies from
russia in a dispute over whether it
should be paid for in euros or rubles
the star pays tribute to the singer tom
parker who died today at the age of 33
having found fame with the boy band the
wanted
and the sun says a masked burglar broke
into the beckham's 40 million pound
mansion in west london while the family
were at home
well reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages while you watch us so let's return
then to
andrew pierce and kevin mcguire um
properly welcome to both of you but
let's go straight andrew chewie to the
times um which is this report
after a long-running scandal with the
times now suggesting that childbirth is
not safe for women in england um how
endemic are the problems that were seen
at this uh this trust
well that was the way when i started
listening to the to the author of the
report the senior maternity officer in
britain talking about this particular
trust you thought why would it only be
happening why was it only happening in
one particular trust these problems were
going on over 20 years
uh warnings were ignored uh
200 children babies probably died that
shouldn't of many more born with all
sorts of abnormalities fractures to
skulls uh breathing problems lack of
oxygen during delivery which is leading
some of these children to develop
conditions like cerebral palsy it really
is staggering that this was going on for
quite so long
and the worry is that this is um a
problem that could be affecting other
trusts and we do not know yet
how bad and severe that issue is what i
think is quite significant though about
this report the chief executive of the
nhl of the trust says she's not going to
resign she's been there for two years
well i suspect she might be more
difficulty than she thinks but
amazingly that trust has had 10 chief
executives in the last 20 years uh and
that sort of churn just can't be good
for continuity and you wonder why so
many of them came and went so quickly
what was the problem were things being
covered up that is the worst part of
this as well for the mothers and the
fathers of these children who died and
the children who were badly injured was
there a cover-up is there a cover-up and
we now know the police are looking at
600 other cases so potentially if there
was a cover-up it could become a
criminal matter that's that's
interesting isn't it um the back to the
the systemic issue uh donna ockendon
report author um kevin uh called for
systemic change across the nhs um she
said that safe maternity care for all
must be the legacy of the babies who
died and certainly you speak to to many
women most women possibly you know most
couples everybody's got a bit of a story
to tell you know of of of elements that
came close for all of their births
effectively and some of the things we
saw in this report like cesarean
sections were discouraged you know the
the natural birthing the culture of
bullying the trust failing to learn from
mistakes and people and really
fundamentally overwork for maternity uh
staff
all of those are hospital aren't they
yeah absolutely i think it's about a
shortage is it 2000 midwives uh i think
i saw the figure but it it's a grim day
for the national health service and that
there will be
expectant mothers and and their partners
will be absolutely terrified uh tonight
after this because
it's gonna clearly go way beyond uh
shrewsbury and telford the problem may
not be as severe but
as donald ockendon has warned it's not
unique and it's going to be widespread
across
england there's going to be going to be
problems there are going to be other
people who've had terrible experiences
of birth and they've lost children or
they've been born
damaged in some way who are now going to
be wondering whether it was because of a
failing rather than uh some something
else it's a it's just really really
awful and of course because it's around
birth it should be the most joyous
moment
in a in a family's experience or the the
birth of a new life and
everybody wants to be happy and
you know it's just
it's just awful it is just so grim this
and i think
the health secretary is going to have to
consider some type of review around the
country now rather than just looking at
one area but those fit those figures
though as andrew said or 201
babies might have died needlessly nine
mothers uh may have also died when they
could have been saved and there's the
guardians picking up uh west mercier
police now investigating 600 cases and
people who
complained or had a terrible experience
they weren't allowed to read reviews
they were too often just brushed off
swept swept aside it's no way to treat
anybody the nhs has a fantastic precious
public service but where they're off
failings
got to be investigated corrected and
called out
yes sir there's the guardian we're
watching out there nhs maternity scandal
police investigating 600 further cases
the figure that you brought up um as
well andrew and the at the times quoting
the 2000 midwife shortage that you
mentioned kevin also saying that four in
ten nhs maternity units in england are
rated as inadequate or requiring
improvement meaning they do not meet
safety standards so clearly a lot of
work to be done certainly
let's move on shall we to ukraine which
is on the front page of the telegraph
and uh we are expecting um overnight in
fact
a speech by sir jeremy fleming the
director of the uk's intelligence cyber
security agency who will say what andrew
well he's he's he's the boss of gchq
which is the great listening center and
he is effectively going to reveal just
how uh this
disorganized and
the lack of discipline within the
russian high command now about the
conduct of this war he's going to say
because they've managed to listen in to
a lot of the conversations in russia
between the military and putin that
putin has been not told what's going on
uh they've been shielding him from how
badly the conscripts and the army are
performing uh about the failure of a
number of strategic objectives and uh
it's a sign that this wall effort is
disintegrating and it also just so
jeremy is going to be saying also that
there is a growing backlash within the
high comm upper echelons of the military
against putin because this is seen as
his war it does remind you more and more
of hitler who was deranged we know and
evil but thought he was also a great
general putin hitler was just a corporal
in the first first world war but took
many of the decisions in the second
world war it's clear putin's been
running a lot of this war himself and he
was a kgb assassin a kgb thug but he's
not a general and it seems that the
morale of the russian army is in a bad
way more and more russian soldiers are
deserting sabotaging their own equipment
and on some cases to jeremy's going to
tell us they've even managed to shoot
down their own aircraft what i mean it
is not funny but it's it just shows a
measure of this once feared fighting
force is becoming a in terms of military
terms a laughing stop well as well as
gchq we've also heard from both the
pentagon and the white house today the
white house communications director kate
bettingfield saying what i can say we
have information that putin felt misled
by the russian military which has
resulted in persistent tension between
putin and his military leadership the
telegraph suggesting he has now sacked
eight generals already now this is what
happens when everyone's so scared of you
they can't speak up kevin
i think that's right if you're if you're
an autocrat
uh you you bark orders
people are not going to tell you the
truth because it may be not what you
want to hear and then you end up in
this disaster it's absolutely terrible
for
ukraine it was an unprovoked uh invasion
uh all my sympathy goes with the
ukrainians
but it's a disaster for putin and russia
too because militarily they've been
shown to be a lot weaker than they uh
they projected and the sanctions will
really bite back uh at home on the on
the economy but the reports are coming
out of the us and uh in the uk they are
just absolutely astonishing and jeremy
fleming i mean he's he's probably got
the biggest ears in britain you know he
is the eavesd dropper in chief gchq
if we have anything world beating it's
uh you know surveillance um sometimes of
course it's concerned about what happens
at home
and innocent people but certainly in
this case he probably knows more what's
happening uh with it within the russian
forces and putin does because he'll be
intercepting almost all the
communications and that's why you can
have so many somebody details now
shooting down their own aircraft yes
that's a low morale but let's not forget
in the iraq war there were blue on blue
uh attack so often by mistake uh
two in american force that i recall
killing some
some uh british service people too but
no it's a it's a disaster for for putin
it's a tragedy for the ukrainians well
we'll certainly listen out for what he
has to say uh that uh
a statement from him coming very shortly
just quickly to the pentagon press
secretary john kirby in the last couple
of hours has said that russia was
withdrawing about 20 of its troops
around kiev and sending them to belarus
with the thought that they would be
resupplying there so we'll keep an eye
on that too
plenty more still to come though
britain's first transgender mp has come
out we will discuss his story when we
come back
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pearce
and kev maguire looking at the story is
in tomorrow's newspapers welcome back to
both of you um so jamie wallace uh front
page of the metro tell us his story then
kevin
yes the
uh jamie wallace the bridge end mp
has said uh he is trans and he was raped
and a blackmailer tried to extort 500
000 pounds to reveal that all and was
subsequently jailed very brave of him to
to come out he actually says i'm trans
or to be more accurate i want to be he
still wants to be called he or him but
is uh
is the first mp uh to to uh uh publicly
uh acknowledged to be tr uh
they're trans and it's a huge amount of
sympathy for him
it's good to have in parliament somebody
who can speak from direct experience on
an issue
which has created a lot of heat on both
sides of the
of the debate and too often it just
results in a
um slagging match which uh it doesn't uh
help anybody and then but it needs a lot
of respect hopefully that'll come boris
johnson welcomed uh him however he was
cracking um transphobic jokes uh last
night at tory fundraising dinner so
maybe maybe having an mp particularly a
conservative mp will make some in the
conservative party and elsewhere other
parties too who make uh cruel jokes
cease and also of the conservatives i
think it'll launch in a culture wars
might have to think twice that's
interesting i don't if you want to
mention i was going to move on to the
star but andrew did you want to pick up
on that just quickly as well
i would just say that the joke boris
johnson made in the speech was actually
at the expense of kierstama who doesn't
appear to know whether a woman uh has
whether a woman can have a penis or not
which is pretty obvious to most people
um a
man that's what he would that's what the
joke was about but um i would say about
uh december i think it's remarkably
courageous of him he put a statement out
at a very odd time three o'clock in the
morning uh and it was an extraordinary
statement and then he put out a second
one and what was really nice to see was
mps from across the commons greeting him
congratulating him supporting him
whether it was kirsten or boris johnson
or the lib dems the smp
because he is the first
maybe he won't be the last
and and uh the quote in the metro um i
have never lived my truth and i'm not
sure how perhaps it starts with telling
everybody so uh uh the words there of of
jamie wallace as he as he uh you know
goes through his process if i can put it
that way um quick look at the daily star
a tragedy of the wanted's tom he fought
until the end wife's tribute as a singer
dies aged just 33. we'll talk about that
a little bit later the wanted singer tom
parker who has died from brain cancer at
the age of 33.
both of you thank you very much indeed
kevin mcguire and andrew pearce see you
shortly thank you very much